[Musique]
c'est une tuie sans explication cette
macabre découverte re chevalier dans le
véhicule TR personnes
[Musique]
mortes
chevaline c'est une affaire qui me h
elle hante tous les enquêteurs qui ont
participé faire appel à une
unitéantierroriste opétion
d'assassinationen légionnaire c'est un
commandité quelque chose de très
[Musique]
grave
surtout c'est c'est une centaine de
gendarmes qui ont été mobilisé en
France c'est un dossier tentaculaire on
a en tout plus de 10000 pièces de
procédure on a dû lancer des commissions
rogatoires dans le monde entier au
Royaume-Uni en Irak aux
[Musique]
États-Unis beaucoup de pistes on a
entendu plein de suspects et puis
souvent on a imaginé des des scénarios
incroyables chevaline c'est sans doute
aujourd'hui la plus grande énigme
judiciaire
[Musique]
française
le 5 septembre 2012 je pars en montagne
avec deux copines à moi bretonne je les
emmène dans un refuge situé au-dessus de
la comedè je connais pas cet endroit j'y
suis jamais on monte
tranquillement j'étais dehors avec ma
fille qui avait 9 ans à l'époque et une
amie à moi et on a entendu les coups de
[Musique]
feu le fait d'être chasseuse ça m'a
interpellé 15h ou 15h15 des coups de feu
il se passe un truc soit c'est un
braconnier
soit j'étais persuadé qu'il se passait
quelque
chose
à quelques kilomètres du village de
chevaline donc à peu près à 2 km un
cycliste descend et nous fait signe de
[Musique]
s'arrêter le cycliste s'avère être un
anglais il parle pas très bien français
il nous dit de pas monter quand je lui
demande pourquoi il faut pas monter il
nous dit il y a qu morts et une petite
fille
vivante et moi je retiens qu'une chose
en fait dans ce qui nous dit c'est qu'il
a une petite fille en
vie et je décide de monter voir ce que
je peux
[Musique]
faire je vais quasiment jusqu'au bout du
parking pour faire un demi tour et je
passe devant vraiment devant la scène de
crime à ce
moment la petite fille a une espèce de
geste que j'ai cru être un dernier geste
en fait elle lève la tête et puis puis
elle retourne puis après il y a plus de
on a plus l'impression qu'elle qu'elle
est en
[Musique]
vie je me rapproche de la voiture je
vois le conducteur qui a des impacts
dans la tête donc je vois vraiment le
l'impact et puis le petit peu de sang
qui coouolle c'est une personne qui est
morte avec un trou un trou rouge
quoi chevaline est vraiment une scène de
crime inhabituelle totalement inabituel
on n voit pas deux dans une carrière
comme ça ça c'est
certain sur cette scène de crime on a un
break BMW qui est buté contre un talu du
du
parking le conducteur qui est affalé sur
son volant il a les bras qui tiennent
encore le
volant et à l'arrière il y a son épouse
qui a été abatue d'une balle dans la
tête et on a une dame un peu plus âgée
qui elle aussi à l'évidence est
décédée et il y a aussi une petite fille
d'environ 7 ans 10 ans qui git sur le
sol elle a visiblement pris une balle
dans le dans le dos elle a des des des
plaies importantes assez profondes sur
le crâne elle porte plusieurs hématomes
à la tête elle a une clavicule cassée
visiblement on s'est acharné sur
elle on essaie d'intervenir et notamment
sur cette petite fille qui est couchée
juste à côté de moi en fait moi je suis
quasiment au niveau de ses pieds et
j'essaie de la toucher j'essaie de de
voir si elle est
vivante la seule chose que j'arrive à
faire c'est lui toucher le pied la soué
et éventuellement essayer de prendre son
pou au niveau de sa chfille ce qui est
pas génial mais pour moi elle est morte
et si je vais vers elle si je la
contourne pour aller lui lui faire un
massagef essayer de faire quelque chose
je me rapproche de la voiture je me
rapproche de la scène de crime et
notamment je me mets à découvert d'un
espèce de bosquet qui est là et
j'yarrive pas la peur fait que bah que
j'arrive
pas je je sais pas pourquoi j'ai j'ai
cette idé là mais pour moi le tueur il
est derrière la
voiture je décide de faire demi-tour et
j'appelle
[Musique]
les vous avez composé le numéro
d'urgence des sa Pompi ne quittez pas un
opérateur va prendre votre
appel on était début septembre à peine
plus loin qu'ici j'ai vu des forces de
l'ordre des pompiers des gendarmes enfin
bref un monde de dingue passer là sur la
partie gauche me doubler à une vitesse
de fou j'avais jamais vu ça je sa pas il
devait rouler à plus de 100
[Musique]
km/h on a reçu l'appel de détresse à
15h45 les premiers arrivés sont les
pompiers et sur place ils appliquent nos
procédures habituelles interdiction de
toucher au cadavre et à quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs et puis à un moment l'un des
pompiers voit que la petite fille a
ouvert les yeux alors il s'est approché
doucement et il l'a vu très saauter
enfin ce sont les mots qu'il a employé
elle reprend connaissance seulement
quelques instants en fait elle va
réussir à dire quelques mots en anglais
alors elle va dire son prénom mais
personne ne le comprend et elle nous
donne aussi son âge 7
ans et puis elle dit qu'elle a très mal
et puis surtout qu'elle ne voit plus
rien sur ce parking le premier sentiment
je vous assure ouais franchement je vous
dirais que moi j'ai quasiment la peur
quoi vous vous regardez par partout
autour de vous vous vous dites mais ça
fait coupegorge enfin franchement c'est
ça fait une
drôleimpression la façon dont ils ont
été tués la position des corps dans dans
les voitures là ils sont à leur
position comme si avent pas pu descendre
comme sils avveit pas pu commencer à
courir à s'échapper enfin bon c'est je
vous assure c'est oui oui c'est
évidemment une scène vous vous rendez
compte quand vous arrivez sur des scènes
comme ça vousz vous êtes pas là pour 2
he il est pas fréquent qu'on
ait heureusement on a mais autant de
morts c'est pas anodin d'avoir tris
adultes un 4è une enfant dont les
secours et les médecins derrière
l'hôpital de grenob vont sauver la vie
oui c'est une scène
extraordinaire à ce stade on a très peu
d'éléments on sait que ce n'est pas un
accident il y a quelque part un tueur et
il est déterminé le procureur de la répu
public en personne se déplace il a de
l'expérience mais face à un tel crime
personne n'est
[Musique]
préparé il était aux alentours de 15h45
16h le collègue vient me voir en
m'indiquant voilà il y a un drame il y a
manifestement plusieurs morts dans un
véhicule et c'est comme ça qu' a démarré
cette affaire assez hors norme qui est
la tuorie de chevaline les enquêtes on
les mène pour les victimes et pour leur
apporter une réponse d'une manière qui
soit totalement incontestable et que
chacun puisse comprendre pourquoi vous
avez eu le malheur de perdre votre père
de perdre votre sœur de perdre votre
mère de perdre votre
grand-mère qui sont ces gens il faut
qu'on essaie de trouver la
vérité manifestement on était en
présence de personnes de nationalité
étrangère britannique sans doute d'une
nationalité autre à l'origine compenue
de leur morphologie ou de leur couleur
de peau simple déduction mais des
étrangers dont on ignorait absolument
tout dans le véhicule trois personnes
trois personnes mortes le conducteur un
homme deux femmes à l'arrière morte à
côté du véhicule un cycliste en tenue de
cycliste il y a le vélo de course un
petit peu plus loin mort
également alors concernant le cycliste
il est sur le dos il est assez près de
la voiture il a toujours son casque sur
la tête et ce casque a été traversé par
une balle il a sa pompe à vélo près de
la jambe gauche et ce qui est marquant
tout de suite hein c'est que son vélo
lui il est à quelques mètres plus haut
alors on fait tout de suite une
déduction il a dû descendre jeter son
vélo et ensuite seulement être
abattu les enquêteurs ils avaient le
sentiment que le cycliste n'avait pas
cette morphologie orientale que
pouvaient avoir les victimes qui se
trouvit dans le véhicule donc leur
première idée a été de se dire que il
n'avaient pas nécessairement de lien
direct a les personnes qui se trouv dans
le
[Musique]
véhicule objectivement pour un touriste
il y a pas de raison d'aller plus loin
et c'est ça qui m'intéresse depuis le
début de cette affaire qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont allés faire
là-bas il est vrai que cette route
forestière porte bien son nom route
forestière est une route qui n'amène à
rien ça fait un quart d'heure qu'on
roule et il y a rien il y a pas un point
de vue il y a pas une clairère pour
piquniquer il y a pas un endroit avec de
bans pour faciliter entre guillemets le
fait de profiter de
[Musique]
l'endroit c'est un endroit sauvage c'est
c'est très sauvage il y a surtout des
Combes des Combes de la colère c'est la
traduction étymologique de H qu'
dire c'est pas une route qu'on emprunte
la qu' dire parce que déjà à l'entrée il
y a un panneau qui vous avertit qu'il y
a des nid poule et je trouve que c'est
une route assez sinistre on comprend
vite qu'on va aller de toute manière
vers un cul de sac donc je pense que le
premier réflexe qu'on a c'est de faire
demi-tour j'habite à dousard depuis
ans souvent j'y allais en fait
j'avouerais que depuis ce jour je suis
pas
retourné pour les enquêteurs toutes les
hypothèses sont ouvertes car le mode
opératoire de cette tuerie laisse
présager soit un règlement de compte
soit un drame familial il y a 3 mois
déjà à chevaline des osmos humains
avaient été retrouvé à la lisière d'un
bois à proximité d'une
tente les enquêteurs avaient sous la
main un certain nombre de techniciens en
investigation criminell les fametiqu qui
sont rattachés au groupement de gendarme
ie de d'y mais on se rend bien compte
qu'on a affaire à une affaire qui sort
de l'ordinaire au regard du nombre de
cadavres et donc à la nécessité de
s'adjoindre un laboratoire de plus
grande envergure il était logique de
faire appel au Laboratoire national de
la gendarmerie donc à
l'IRCGN faut faire venir le département
de la balistique et puis de la biologie
et des empreunes
digitales quand vous faites venir des
experts en balistique on ne doit pas
ouvrir les portes ère de parce que là
tous les morceaux de ver qui sont encore
présents sur la sur la ptière risquent
de tomber que ce soit en intérieur en
extérieur et c'est très perturbant bien
évidemment pour les les expertises à
venir donc avec les avec les pompiers
avec les médecins ils s'entendent sur le
fait que on ne va pas sortir les corps
qui sont dans la voiture interdiction de
pénétrer dans la voiture ni même
d'ouvrir les portières on attend les
techniciens de la gendarmerie
scientifique venu de Paris la première
PHAs c'est ratissage donc on a un
maximum de personnel qui ont ratissé la
zone voilà et après on va exploiter tous
les éléments les témoignages ça va
évidemment continuer tout au long de la
nuit si la gendarmerie effectivement
prend autant de précaution et autant de
moyens c'est que elle garde en mémoire
le drame et la tragédie de l'affire
Grégory là où malheureusement une scène
de crime a été sacagé et piétiné par X
personnes qui n'avaient rien à y faire
qui ont sans doute on
trvé des résultats qui aurait pu être
bien plus précoce donc voilà la
gendarmerie elle garde ça comme un
traumatisme et on lui a appris à geler
la scène de crime parfois trop
peut-être je suis le premier journaliste
arrivé sur
place donc j'ai vu le gendarme qui est
un peu paniqué de me voir arriver tout
seul parce que je pense qu'il a dû avoir
certainement l'ordre de protéger la
scène de crime que personne rentre à
proximité de la zone de crime mais là je
me souviens très bien de son visage j'ai
vu la peur dans son visage et j'ai
compris que c'était quelque chose de
très grave naaliez que nous trouvons sur
place en direct Nathalie bonjour
dites-nous d'abord quelles sont les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez on sent un vrai vent de panique
sur place parce que les gendarmes sont
des gendarmes locaux qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de ce type de fait
divers tout d'un coup une énorme affaire
et qui plus lorsqu'on apprend qu' s'agit
d'une famille britannique c'est une
affaire ensuite qui dépasse nos
frontières donc ça se transforme en chet
divers
international c'est assez étonnant c'est
c'est une des premières fois pour moi
que les journalistes arrivent aussi vite
S ou aux abords en tout cas d'une d'une
scène de crime à partir du moment où les
médias ont commencé à en parler dès
l'après-midi même enfin dès
l'après-midi entre 16h et 19h c'est
c'est vrai que le timing est pourtant
assez serré mais j' dirais à partir de
17h les radios ont commencé à en parler
évidemment que l'information s'est
diffusée assez vite et à moins d'une
heure vous aviez déjà beaucoup de
journalistes et notamment des
journalistes britanniques ces
journalistes anglais arriv avec des
portant avec des vêtements avec tout un
avec des camions où ils installent
carrément des plateaux de télé à
cheval j'étais dans le premier vol
Londres
Genève il y avait d'autres équipes de
tournage des équipes de télévision et
des journalistes dans le même
vol rien de tel n'était jamais arrivé à
H
et on peut dire qu'il ne savait vraiment
pas comment gérer tout ce
[Musique]
monde il faut que ça soit fait lou coû
ch un
se les photos et distribes
les
[Musique]
les gendarmes pensent qu'il s'agit d'un
hélicoptère de la gendarmerie évidemment
on peut penser effectivement que des
experts ont besoin de prendre des photos
en hauteur pour savoir bon ensuite c'est
vrai que ça a été très très très mal
pris lorsqu'ils ont appris qu'il
s'agissait de journalistes britannique
qui souhaitait avoir un
[Musique]
scoop que s'est-il passé sur les
hauteurs du lac d'Any un endroit
d'ordinaire paisible fréquenté par les
randonneurs c'est donc là qu'une famille
britannique a été massacrée ainsi qu'un
Français sans doute là par hasard au
mauvais moment l'information commence à
se répandre on commence à en parler et
sur les chaînes infos et à la radio et
c'est ce qui a amené ensuite à un appel
téléphonique qui va déclencher une
accélération de l'enquête en tout cas
une accélération des investigations sur
ce véhicule c'est un coup de fil du
gérant d'un camping Le le camping le
solitaire et qui a appelé comme tout
gérant de camping il connaî 16 gendarmes
les gendarmes du secteur ils les
connaissent par cœur il se tut toi donc
il y a il y a aucune hésitation à les
appeler il les appelle en disant mais
j'entends dire j'entends parler de ces
cadavres qui ont été découverts on parle
d'une petite fille on parle de gens
manifestement du Moyen-Orient d'un
véhicule anglais ça me rappelle des gens
qui sont chez moi qui sont en caravane
en camping en vacances chez moi je suis
allé voir effectivement il y a personne
il y a plus le véhicule et c'est à ce
moment-là que le gérant du camping
lordordi mais il y a pas une fillette il
y en a deux
[Musique]
les gendarmes arrêtent leurs
investigations extrêmement
précautionneuses et accélèent le rythme
parce que pour le coup il y a peut-être
un danger
vital qu'est-ce qui s'est passé est-ce
que la petite fille a été enlevée c'est
ce qu'on se dit tout de suite il ne
savent pas si la petite fille qui est
évoquée a été tuée exécutée dans les
bois un peu plus loin ou si B aant eu
peur elle est partie quelque
part pendant qu'on élargit le périmètre
de recherche pour la petite Zina les
premières informations sur les autres
membres de cette famille anglaise
arrivent donc on essaie de s'intéresser
à qui sont d'où ils viennent sont des
iraakiens qui vivent à Londres le père
la mère la grand-mère et leur
fillettes
[Musique]
il est ingénieur aéronautique c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille dans le milieu
de l'aviation alors c il a une vie
d'ingénieur il est à l'aise il a une
jolie maison classique à colombage
britannique ass belle maison ancienne la
banlieu de
Londres une femme irakienne
elle s'appelait higbili
elle était dentiste et c'était sans
doute la plus discrète des
deux sad était très extraverti et
familier elle elle était plus
introvertie et
Tim Kbal était très amoureuse de son
mari la seule chose c'est que elle était
à l'arrière de la voiture parce que elle
a le mal de la voiture c'est
à l'avant elle est malade c'est pour ça
que la petite était
devant je me souviens du jour où on
était chercher la caravane quand il l'a
acheté nous avons conduit sur
l'autoroute jusqu'à l'endroit où il
l'avait acheté et on l'a remorqué
jusqu'à
[Musique]
clayate parfois il partait à 10 km de
chez eux à peine pour le
weekend partir de la maison juste par
amour du
camping la caravane avait été nommée
spoti par Zenab
elle était toujours garée devant la
maison et les enfants jouaient
dedans c'était une famille heureuse sad
était particulièrement attentionné
envers ces deux
filles il les adorait
vraiment quand elles entraent dans une
pièce il répétait toutes les phrases
deux fois une fois en arabe et une fois
en anglais
[Musique]
systématiquement les techniciens en
investigation criminelle étaai étaai
évidemment tous sur place et c'est à ce
moment-là donc il se dirige vers le
véhicule ouvre les portes qu'il n'avait
pas encore fait et à ce moment-là il
voit un mouvement sous les jupes à
l'oriental les deux femmes qui se
trouvaient à l'arrière du véhicule et
qui à ce moment-là se révèle parce que
c'est vraiment comme ça que ça s'est
produit une petite fille qui était là
depuis de nombreuses heures totalement
immobile est retrouvé 8h après oui c'est
énorme ouais ça paraît complètement
énorme quand on vous le quand on vous le
dit oui elle est resté prostrée sans
bouger donc elle a passé 8h sous les
jupes de sa maman morte assassinée sans
rien dire sans un bruit sans rien alors
on imagine ce qu'a pu vivre cet enfant à
ce moment-là on imagine la terreur de
cet enfant qui a dû entendre les coups
de feu qui a pas compris réellement ce
qui s'était passé mais qui qui a bien dû
sentir que plus rien ne bougeit que plus
rien ne se passait que personne venait
la chercher vous imaginez le bruit la la
zone a été survolée par un hélicoptère
il y a les camions les véhicules des
pompiers les véhicules de la gendarmerie
les radios les gens qui communiquent par
téléphone donc on peut imaginer à quel
point ils sont peut-être
incompréhensible aussi pour une enfant
de cet âge-là à quoi il se rattache
l'odeur certain ement du sang de la mort
l'odeur de la mort elle est dans une
voiture avec trois
morts franchement on pensait avoir tout
faitin tout ce qu'il fallait faire en
tout cas le site a été survolé par un
hélicoptère spécialisé avec une caméra
thermique il n'a repéré aucune chaleur
aucune trace de vie rien du tout donc
quand on a fini par comprendre qu'elle
était là on était tous très amers en
colère
même
mais on était aussi très heureux de la
voir apparaître
vivante ce soir là tous ceux qui vont
approcher la voiture vont vivre une
scène absolument déchirante parce qu'on
a une petite fille qui est indemne dans
une scène
atroce l'enfant est récupéré par un
gendarme qui la sort en lui mettant la
main sur les yeux pour éviter qu'elle ne
voit la scène de crime et elle est
confié à une judante de gendarmerie qui
pr en charge
aussitôt on était sur une image vraiment
cinématographique un ciel d'ancre une
lumière blafarde lié aux éclairages de
la gendarmerie et puis pourquoi ça je ne
le sauraai jamais mais curieusement
cette fillette a été amenée vers nous
qui étions à l'extérieur de la de la
scène de crime non pas blotti dans les
bras de l'enquêtrice qui aurait été on
ne peut plus naturel mais en fait comme
certaines peintures du CH enfant assis
visage face aux interlocuteurs dans les
bras de l'enquêrice position très
étrange qui fait qu'effectivement tous
ceux qui étaient là don moi ont vu cette
petite fille et ces boucles blondes à un
moment donné se mettre à
sourire c'est un moment de pure émotion
soudain il y a plus d'enquêteur il y a
que des pères et des mères de famille
autour de cette scène de crime et un
immense soulagement de savoir que les
deux fillettes sont
vivantes
[Applaudissements]
alors elle est indemne physiquement en
tout cas et ben même si elle n'a que 4
ans elle parle c'est la seule personne à
pouvoir raconter éventuellement ce qui
s'est réellement passé elle va dire très
vite qu'elle s'appelle Zina elle va dire
qu'elle a entendu effectivement des des
Banges ensuite elle va raconter au
gendarmes qu'elle a entendu son son père
tenté de faire démarrer la voiture qui
n'y arrivait pas sans doute dans la
panique et elle a un détail atroce elle
va raconter que il y a un filet de sang
qui coule de la bouche de de sa mère et
puis surtout elle va
dire papa maman not live et voilà elle a
4 ans elle a vécu une scène traumatique
et elle a compris que ses parents
étaient morts on a basculé là dans
l'horreur
[Musique]
totale concernant la petite fille de 8
ans retrouvée grièvement blessée euh sur
les lieux du crime elle a été opérée la
la nuit dernière il faudra attendre
qu'elle soit totalement rétablie pour
pouvoir commencer à l'interroger quant à
sa petite sœur de 4 ans qui elle a été
retrouvé miraculeusement indemne elle va
beaucoup mieux elle aurait commencé ce
matin à parler aux enquêteurs on n' pas
pu l'entendre en tout cas pas avant le
lendemain à l'hôpital c'est dur parce
que elle n'a que 4 ans elle est prostrée
sur son lit et puis elle pleur
beaucoup alors on a découvert en fait
que avec une infirmière si on lui lit
des livres en anglais elle se calme un
peu elle commence à nous raconter ce
qu'elle a vu enfin surtout
[Musique]
entendu quand ils sont arrivé à ce
qu'elle appelle le lieu the place en
anglais son papa et sa sœur sont sortis
de la voiture les trois passagers
arrière voulait descendre aussi mais la
chose enfin c'est l'expression
qu'utilise Zina pour parler des faits
la chose a commencé donc
elles n'ont pas pu descendre alors elle
elle a assimilé tout ça à un feu
d'artifice
elle a entendu son père hurler le prénom
de sa sœur mais zenableîné n'est jamais
remonté dans la
voiture la petite dit qu'elle a eu très
peur elle a senti un danger et alors
elle se'est tout de suite caché au pied
de sa maman sous sa robe et et elle a
attendu et quand le silence est revenu
elle dit qu'elle a osé parler et qu'elle
a
demandé
si enfin qu'est-ce que c'était que cette
chose
évidemment personne n'a
[Musique]
répondu
c'est dès le début une affaire
extrêmement mystérieuse personne ne
comprend rien tout est paradoxal une
famille tranquille de britannique en
vacances qui se fait assassiner sur un
parking en montagne avec leurs
enfants le but du jeu c'est de
comprendre qui est cette famille d'où
ils viennent est-ce que ce sont des des
des véritables touristes est-ce que
cette affaire elle cache pas non plus
autre chose à ce stade-là vous n'avez
que des points d'interrogation on a les
identités on sait maintenant qui sont
les victimes reste à savoir pourquoi
elles étaient là ce qu'ell faisaient en
France et on sait d'emblé que ça va être
une enquête
[Musique]
compliquée les journaux britanique on
apprend aussi que donc la victime avait
perdu ses parents et qu'il y avait un
litige au cœur de la famille sur une
histoire d'éréage çaad Lili lorsqu'il
est donc venu en France l'un de ses
objectifs C é de se rendre en Suisse à
un moment ou un autre il avait pris
rendez-vous dans cette banque où se
trouvaient les fonds déposés par le
père son objectif c'était de d'essayer
de reconstituer la totalité du
patrimoine du père et d'en prendre en
quelque sorte le
contrôle la fortune de la famille Alili
se comptait quand même en quelques
millions d'euros enfin on n'est pas sur
un tout petit
héritage on voit tout de suite qu' a des
zones d'ombre dans cette famille toutes
les familles ont des mystères des
secrets pas
tout il faut s'intéresser à l'identité
des
victimes car dans presque 90 % des cas
le tueur a un lien direct avec la
victime sa plus grande crainte c'était
son
[Musique]
frère